welcome back to new rock stars marvel's
eternals have introduced celestials
fully into the mcu but what does that
existence of these cosmic overlords mean
to the rest of the mcu going forward
where will we see them next is it time
to go to war with our daddies
this is rogue theory
it's a show where we pitch the wildest
theories for the nerdy titles we love
and whether you have seen eternals yet
or you haven't don't worry it is the
friday after this movie has come out not
all of you might have had a chance to
see it yet so we are not going to spoil
the eternals film at all for you viewers
of this video we're just going to look
ahead to marvel's future now that the
celestials are just active players in
this universe how does it really change
the game i'm eric voss going rogue with
me today is our own protector of the
nerd universe jessica clemens
uh good day
hey julio
i wish you had a hat to tip good day
the only point of hats it's just so you
can tip them
um also the one making sure humanity
keeps moving in the right direction with
thoughtful media analysis it's whitney
van laningham
hi hello
hello hey
howdy buckaroos
and finally uh the cosmic judge who
gives us an upvote or a downed vote and
make sure this rogue's theory
gets to continue on or be disqualified
is empty
yes i am irishm the judge i will judge
all humanity when the time comes so be
on my good side all right and he's not
gonna tell you he's gonna do a drop-in
judge he's gonna be like you're guilty
i've got a list and i'm checking it
twice so better watch out
oh
santa celestial confirmed we'll find out
santa celestial sounds like a nightmare
oh my god that'd be terrible
year-round naughty list dude well
eternals introduces us to the celestials
of course the cosmic armored space gods
of marvel lore they created earth the
planets everything mankind as we know it
but uh by this movie's end
not spoiling anything we're just you
know as we are anytime a marvel movie
introduces a new facet of the universe
we are left wondering how many more of
these things are there uh when will we
see these things next well how does it
reframe everything we thought we knew
and uh we're now wondering that about
the celestials like in what mcu title
specifically will we see them next we
got thor love and thunder in the
pipeline the marvels you know captain
marvel 2 we got guardians of the galaxy
vol 3. fantastic four these are all like
the space set titles that are coming to
mind right now but there's also loki
season two we're gonna know how the
celestials fit in with the tva with kang
but uh is it possible we could be headed
toward a celestial war oh
okay
interesting i think that we're going to
see the celestials next in thor love and
thunder considering that this movie is
going to be all about gore the god
butcher and you know he's going around
killing all these celestial type figures
these celestial gods and so we're gonna
we're probably going to see that gore
the god butcher was responsible for the
beheading of nowhere the celestial from
guardians of the galaxy one because he
has this like super powerful sword that
can like kill gods and like you know
slice off celestial heads in in the
comics and and i think this is what
peter pill's role in 411 thunder is
going to be he's going to be this like
member of the celestial race that gore
needs to kill because he's like oh man i
missed one i'll get them um so i think
that we'll see like at least a flashback
at the very least of um gore dealing
with celestials i like that idea a lot
mt i wonder if like an alternate title
for thor 11 thunder could be something
like kill all celestials you know that's
that's gore's motive is he just wants to
kill every every celestial in existence
everything that's a directly uh lineage
of the celestials uh and yeah that
includes peter quill right like
i think that would be a fascinating and
we might learn something about like the
asgardian connection to the celestials
there's like versions of it in the
comics but like in the movies they may
establish that
what makes the asgardians so godly is
that uh they were like another version
of eternals but not what was in this
movie but instead like they were like
the chosen people of the celestials or
something like that i don't know we'll
see
um but i love that idea a lot empty does
anyone else have another idea when we
might see the celestials again i'd like
to see the celestials uh
during
um guardians of the galaxy um only
because we're already entering that just
giant world of space and time with adam
warlock that this is something that
could disrupt enough for the celestials
to come back and just blow up the
sovereign planet um i think that's that
would be very fun to see especially when
we think that adam warlock is going to
be on the side of the guardians and
start maybe possibly work with them he's
such a big entity like even when he like
in the comics work like finding thanos
thanos i think it's still it shows that
this is a big person we kind of missed
it with ego we kind of missed it with
thanos like the celestials could come
back
and do something about this because they
need to talk more about and explore more
of the whole ego situation being
destroyed that's too big for it to go
unnoticed so i think to stay cannon they
can just bring the celestials and
turtles into it i really do like that
idea jess because like you know if you
think about the sovereign as a society
they're all about evolution and like
they're purposely you know evolving
their people to to be better and i think
the celestial will probably be like hold
on a minute yeah that's not right second
yeah it's our job
what kind of kick in the nuts would that
be to the leader to be like
i've been doing everything right like
our people are perfect and it's like
no
are they though i got oh no
i thought that
was not good like we're not gonna do
that again and blow that planet up um
and for adam warlock to like look from
afar and be like oh [ __ ]
those were my people technically um i
think that's a big deal i mean james
gunn was the person who introduced
celestials to the mcu with the first
guardians movie with esau on the
searcher i'd love to hear more of that
backstory uh and to hear like the the
exact logic of ego the living planet
just saying he's a celestial but having
this human corporeal form on the planet
like are there other people who are just
walking around on planets just
celestials deciding to walk the way that
like i don't know if you want to see
some biblical yeah comparison here that
god
you know that's kind of what ego did
i'm sure there are and that would be fun
that's the thing is you can explore this
and make it so much more you can make it
more grounded but you can bring in so
you can incorporate so much if you
brought them into guardians i think
because it's like yeah what if they are
walking around the planets just as
humans or what if they just have an
ulterior motive that is just like
destroy planets anyways um there's just
so many that you can work with and also
i just love guardians of the galaxy so
make it bigger make it bigger yeah i i
do have this weird theory that the
collector and the grand master are
actually secretly celestials um like
like celestial barriers
so like i think it make there is more
precedent to that um the the grand
master being a celestial is such an a
useless thing
because like the grand master dress is
like zero in the tester and he tests
people's might all the time so i'm just
like it makes sense
the collector gathers people like gammon
on the gatherer so i'm just like this is
weird and like uh what's his face uh ego
was uh essentially the gardener from the
comics from the marvel comics he dressed
like the gardener so i'm just like these
are all
elderly universe celestial links i don't
know it's kind of weird to me anyway i'm
just rambling what you got i think that
would work that would definitely
simplify a lot on the cosmic levels of
the tears in the marvel cinematic
universe if you just made elders the
same thing as celestials
like i don't know it just depends how
far
uh nate moore and kevin feige and
victoria alonso louis museum all these
people trust uh fans of the marvel
cinematic universe to have these
different categories of cosmic beans and
be able to keep them all straight in
their heads at any given moment uh or do
they want to just like simplify and
streamline it and just have you have as
guardians eternals and then above that
you got the real gods and then
everything about you
our gods which are celestials what do
you think whitney right on man
um so i was wondering when i was doing a
little reading up on celestials before
bedtime um
i came across a storyline from the
comics where and i probably am not going
to say the celestial's name right
because i have no idea how to pronounce
this i have never tried but it
looks like it's spelled progenitor so
like
p-r-o-g-e-n-i-t-r so like progenitor
right like that sounds okay cool uh so
he was a celestial that um loki told
stories of that had gotten infected by
the horde and had come to earth
essentially to die four million years
ago and that he had been like his body
is still like buried and decaying within
the earth and that the fluids that his
decaying body started seeping out is one
of the factors that caused there to be
superheroes on earth and so that's like
a cool little cool little loki storyline
uh in the comics that he ends up talking
about so i'm wondering if we will see
anything about that brought up in loki
when that that'd be sound that would be
so that would be like the best like
because you just like melt there isn't
melted like the blood or oil or whatever
made yeah like superheroes that would be
juices
it's such a small yeah just fluid just
uh just fluid um it just fell out but i
think it's still like so plausible that
that one could happen because it's also
just like a side tad bit that's like
maybe we'll see this soon and it's like
they're able to still
like find this corpse of the celestial
maybe there's still powers left inside
of it maybe that's something that like
loki could lead them to because he's the
one who knows the
mythology of all this yeah so yeah i
mean and we also have you know the
introduction of the celestials in the
eternals movies so like once that yeah
you know marvel studios introduces the
celestials then i feel like the shows
can be like all right now we can play
with the elements that have already been
introduced and since loki is all about
time travel and the celestials are these
super old beings it makes sense for the
celestials to pop up and loki so i think
that's a really good one um idea
yeah it also proves that if one of them
could be killed and infected by
something that the others can be too
so they might even be able to study what
happened with him to use it as knowledge
fighting celestials going forward yeah
i i think you bring up an interesting
point whitney that like all over the
cosmic universe in the mcu
like it's implied that like celestials
created all of that so what is your
relationship with all these other races
the the cree of holla the the squirrel
of torfa you know like i i kind of want
to see that play out i mean that's
another reason i brought up uh the
marvels is like we we need to revisit
these other settings in the emcee these
are giant empires with a vast
millennia of culture and history and
politics and strife and i and i want to
see
them go through uh kind of a celestial
uh conflict of realizing that you have
these you've been uh overseen by a
helicopter parent you're actually on one
of those leashes at disneyland your
whole existence you know um kid leashes
are the saddest things i've ever seen
they really are i'm sorry sometimes you
see a child
sometimes you imagine eric boss is a
child you guys
what would make that life better if you
put him on a leash and so
he's he's he runs rampant he runs crazy
i don't know i mean i was at disneyland
not too long ago
oh you gotta lease that boy up eric
unleashed my uh my fiance we saw a kid
who's on a leash and uh kelly was like
we need one of those for you and i was
like i do need one i want you yeah
she looked back and said we need one of
those for you and he's already gone
to go get me a leash and they come back
like one of those dogs in a park that
just has a loose juice i'm like
you're my nestor now
you're at the mall
yeah
where's my guardian i'm picturing you
doing the thing that like my dog has to
do or i have him like step his paws into
the harness and then wiggle it on like
you just are like a well-trained dog
yeah now we do know that you know miss
marvel's powers are going to be more
cosmic-based like you know monica and
carol's the marvels are probably going
to go into like the like how these these
women got these powers and what makes
them marvelous and so maybe the
celestials will pop up and then we'll
find out you know the the celestial
science behind why you know human beings
can become marvelous or superpowered so
i think they could pop up there that's a
cool idea i like that a lot um some
great thoughts here i'm just very
excited to see these big old colorful
things next yes uh even if it's just
them playing volleyball with jupiter i
want to see their four square with
neptune that's all i want i want a whole
movie of just that um but just to award
some points uh jessica you get a rogie
for your idea of uh showing up in
guardians volume three i i think that's
a great idea i would love to see that uh
whitney i'm gonna give you two rogies uh
this idea of um
of like the reason why any superheroes
exist anywhere uh is because of a
celestial blood
uh just growing in the soil uh empty
though uh three points i think gore the
god butcher having a mission of
literally butchering these gods of
killing all the celestials i think
that's perfect that's a perfect
backstory for his character but also
this implication that the marvels you
know might have uh might have some
connection to those celestials as well
uh i i think that's that's a cool way to
link all the different superheroes just
to explain uh how superhero dumb exists
in this universe um
so let me know your theories in the
comments below viewer where do you want
to see the celestials next who do you
think would win in a fight between them
and gore and these other characters i
guess we'll find out soon enough but
there is a brand new latest obsession
shirt inspired by the marvel's eternals
available at newrockstarsmerge.com it
looks awesome these are limited edition
shirts and once they sell out they are
retired to the blue dungeon so only i
get them yeah
so you you gotta grab one as soon as
possible find those shirts and all of
the great merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com
we want to thank bespoke post for
sponsoring this episode bespoke post has
a new seasonal lineup of must-have box
of awesome collections bespoke partners
with small businesses and emerging
brands to bring you the most unique
goods every month in the past i've
gotten some great warm clothes camping
supplies and cooking gear from bespoke
post no matter what you're into box of
awesome has you covered box of awesome
has collections for every part of your
life they have cool boxes for making
coffee while camping making some killer
tacos even some throwy knives and that's
for after the coffee kicks in to get
started take the quits at box of
awesome.com your answers will help them
pick the right box of awesome for you
they release new boxes every month
across a ton of different categories
it's free to sign up and you can skip a
month or cancel anytime each box costs
only 45 bucks but has over 70 dollars
worth of gear inside plus with each box
off awesome you're supporting small
businesses 90 of everything that comes
in your box of awesome is from a small
up-and-coming brand get 20 off your
first monthly box of awesome when you
sign up at box of awesome.com and enter
the code rogue at checkout that's box of
awesome.com code rogue for 20 off your
first box of awesome also i recently got
some socks from one of the sponsors of
this episode stance and they are both
incredibly comfortable and well designed
they feel great and they're you know
they're kind of funky in looks not in
smell
they smell great when i put them on
after i've had them on all day i can't
promise that but stance was founded in
2009 and stance apparel has reinvented
socks t-shirts and more they have a
sharp focus on comfort quality and
creativity stance brings in atypical
aesthetic alongside some of pop
culture's hottest collaborators for the
ultimate in style and self-expression
because everything you wear should be a
direct extension of who you are and how
you feel they do a lot of stylish
collaborations with brands you love they
currently have sock collaborations with
batman pixar star wars and a bunch of
cool designers and artists i might need
to grab some of their marvel designs i
know they'll be incredibly comfortable
and they look really cool the stance
philosophy is
the stats philosophy is that a perfect
fit is more important than simply
fitting in that those who feel good do
good go see for yourself just head on
over to stance.com and pick out whatever
styles you like enjoy the color and
comfort of a life less ordinary with
stance also there's an incredible app
everyone who buys gas needs to know
about it's called get upside our
audience can make up to 25 cents for
every gallon of gas every time they fill
up just download the free get upside app
on the app store or google play right
now use promo code rogue and get a bonus
25 cents per gallon on your first fill
up that's up to 50 cents cash back don't
pay full price to the pump anymore get
cash back using get upside just download
the app for free and use the promo code
rogue to get up to 50 cents per gallon
cash back on your first tank some people
who drive a lot are making as much as
two to three hundred dollars a month in
cash back and there's no catch the cash
back gets added right to your account
you get cash out any time of your bank
account paypal or an e-gift card for
amazon and other brands just download
the free get upside app and use promo
code rogue to get up to 50 cents per
gallon cashback on your first tank
that's code rogue all right uh in other
news this week we just got a new tv
promo for hawkeye coming on disney plus
thanksgiving weekend which features
clint barton and kate bishop talking to
kate's mother eleanor bishop played by
vera farmiga and we think maybe she
could be the villain madam mask on this
show we'll find out but in this clip she
asks kate you're helping him with an
avengers level threat now from what we
can tell so far about the hawkeye series
clint barton is just visiting new york
with his family right before the
holidays and then he realizes that some
vigilante is copycatting his old ronin
getup so he stays behind and then he
gets sucked into all this drama with a
tracksuit dracula gang
but could there be a bigger true
avengers level threat that we are not
yet seen from this show like assuming
clint and kate are telling eleanor the
truth in this moment that they actually
have some threat that eleanor might even
know about that she's like whoa you're
how you're fighting that
is there a true adventurous level threat
in the hawkeye series and if so what do
you think that threat could be
i'll go first so i think a good hawkeye
avengers level threat would probably be
like having bullseye come back um and
having bullseye be just mimicking uh
clint i think that would be very fun to
see so the last time we saw bullseye he
was getting his back worked on you
talking about daredevil season three yes
yeah on netflix so yes i know yes
wait are we talking about the 2003 uh
ben affleck daredevil with [ __ ]
we're talking about netflix
we had a more recent bullseye that's
right we saw his bad game worked on so i
think when we see his back end worked on
with that medal he's gonna be more
efficient more better as a soldier i
think that'd be greater to see him play
against clint barton and i but i do
think that would be like this there will
be two threats they'll be like what we
see with the tracksuit guys actually
doing their [ __ ] and then i think this
guy's like i'm a hero i think it's a
good introduction also because we're
having so if we did do the dark avengers
let's say if we did do dark avengers
this way we could be so we're already
pulling elena in right
going after the original clint not
bullseye clint the original clan and
then if we wanted to put instead we put
john walker as captain america in that
bunch it it would wrap up in such a
tight like a tight-knit bow that i think
it would be fun to see and they have
that for the series going forward rather
than like the entire big movies coming
forward so i think for siri's sake if we
do like dark avengers stuff we put him
bullseye i think he would be the next
level of avengers style threat he's like
a metal man now right he's made with the
same
game
yeah and he's yeah with that same deadly
aim and also if they did want to bring
in i guess they could also bring in
taskmaster but i don't think taskmaster
i don't know i don't know what i think
about taskmaster after
i don't think marvel knows what it
thinks about him
i think they need to um
if they want to bring if they want to
bring her in bring her in but i also
don't think they're going to bring her
yeah
but yeah that's what i think that threat
would be bullseye that's cool i uh
i know that in the comics there is a big
old storyline where um
kate and hawkeye fight scrolls together
there's a big old scroll invasion that
takes place a secret invasion
i think that because we know that there
are skrulls walking among us now
i think that that could be a possibility
that they could be
investigating some sort of scroll
invasion perhaps the ronin copycat is a
scroll disguising themselves it's ronin
oh my gosh
okay
interesting maybe
see i think the ronin copycat is just
kate bishop but you're saying like
there's gonna be a moment where kate and
clint are watching tv and they're like
wait if you're here who's on the tv
yeah who's the new ronin w h i h the if
you know i just i think it'd be okay
i love that i mean i think anything with
scrolls that's fine they should be
everywhere i think scrolls are just fun
man i mean yeah yeah
i know i really do like the scroll idea
um i think that we could be
going somewhere like deeper i think
we're i think the threat could be an
organization maybe potentially an
organization teased in uh you know age
of ultron uh the intelligence yeah the
intellectia um of the marvel comics i i
always mix up the intelligence of the
the illuminati it is the intelligentsia
not the intelligentsia i've been saying
i don't know i've never that's because
of the intelligentsia coffee shop in
silverlake
i mean that is why i i have a record of
uh mispronouncing things so you know i
do too oh i do too there's a secret
organization of like the the smartest
criminal minds that i think that val may
be a part of and i think that they're
actually the ones who set up the hit on
hawkeye they're like you know what we
got to take down the avengers because
they're this huge problem and uh you
know luckily we got a black widow out of
the picture in uh in avengers end game
so now we just gotta
gotta methodically get rid of the rest
and so i think val and we i think um you
know eventually we'll get um
zemo doctor doom like all the smartest
people in the mcu coming together to
take down the avengers from the shadows
which is why um and we'll start to see
that in hawkeye and aka's like who's
trying to kill us
so i think that's the the secret threat
there
extra i think
i like that idea a lot i would love it
if like kingpin could also be tied in
with that you know like it seems like
they are doing some similar stuff from
the mat fraction david aha siri a lot of
similar stuff right but part of that was
that auction right that had the um the
embarrassing video of hawkeye of him
assassinating someone and i really think
that footage of him unmasking himself as
the ronin assassin i mean that the world
yet doesn't know they know that there
was a ronin assassin they don't know it
was clint barton only rhodey did it and
rhodey was like
uh so natasha he tried to do that thing
like so you're the werewolf right and
like you know
and she's like
i didn't say it no he's trying he's like
okay
um but like i think yeah like
intelligence organizations kind of knew
but it wasn't publicly known and i think
clint is worried about that getting out
and i think that's kind of what maybe
you're right empty maybe this group
could be part of exposing that working
with val you know i think that's why val
had uh it's gonna be something tied in
with that some kind of dark avenger some
kind of intelligence organization that
is embedded in the us government because
she that i think the answer to this
question is who is val working for
you know once we know who val is working
for i think we're going to know what's
really going on behind i think val is
secretly the new red skull i think that
she's the red skull's like daughter or
niece or like sin in the comics she's
the schmidt
because like you know if you if you look
at the way she's dressed in the black
widow post for credit scene it's kind of
very similar to like uh like the old
school red skull she had a little flap
of skin that she could pull off
yeah i could see a little bit of the red
skin just not cold at a cemetery mt is
that what you got no but like i think
that there are some i think there are
purposeful parallels between the way she
was dressed in the way that red skull
was dressed you know during his white
skin phase like his uh his um
i guess
um but anyway that's just me being weird
man you you took a you took a pretty
sturdy theory and you went rogue with it
empty so for that reason you're getting
a point empty gets the point for that
round uh i'm super excited for hawkeye
obviously new rockstars is going to be
doing all of our weekly coverage on
hawkeye when that drops so stay tuned
for that um but let us now move on to
our rogue question round it was
announced this week that our friend
chris pratt is gonna be doing the voice
of garfield in an upcoming animated film
internet lost their minds because this
comes on the heels of the announcement
that he's also gonna be voicing mario in
a movie so i want you guys to pitch me
the next beloved animated character that
people are gonna hate
even more to learn that chris pratt is
voicing that one too
[Laughter]
oh this is a good question there's so
many you know what i would hate you know
what i'd really really [ __ ] hate if
his next thing was he was gonna play
like
power line and the live action
i would be so furious but it's a move
they would do it's a mu they would
absolutely be like let's make him the
coolest character we can think of in the
disney franchise and power line and it's
like first off that's a black guy
second of all
god stop putting him in things he can't
i could see i could see disney doing
that i could see put him in a tight
yellow suit
yeah i can't fight him but i'd fight him
if he did that you know what i think
that chris pratt's next role is going to
be that of uh fat albert i think they're
just going to cast him
hey hey
hey yeah
as a fat black guy
fat albert
i'm just kidding no that's that's a joke
that answers the question i like the
internet get super pissed
i mean you know it was also made by bill
cosby so that's probably that
even more so
um
the only character i want him as
i just wait
oh my god albert he's part of his group
oh my god mushroom that's hilarious i
didn't hear that i'd be like get him out
get him out though
so yeah either fat albert or snoopy is
what um chris pratt oh snoopy now talks
and his voice is
chris brown i think that uh
i would most [ __ ] hate chris pratt in
a live action or even animated calvin
and hobbes oh my god ultimately would
ultimately destroy me as a human being
and i don't think i would be able to
continue on
you know what might have accidentally
guessed his next move yeah i think
that's what sucks about that is they
probably will let him voice
wow wow that's like the live action
calvin and hobbes and it's like why are
you playing a child
oh no he where are you
why are you if you're not the child i
don't know
a dear evan hansen situation all over
again but with chris pratt it's a live
action kid and they're just like the
other voice over the kids whitney you
get the point for that one because it's
just too scarily real okay it's two plus
it's probably gonna happen honestly wow
oh boy and i say that
i'm sorry it's too real and i hope i
didn't just manifest it
i still kind of i like chris pratt i i
don't have a problem with that guy uh
and i think he's great as peter quill uh
there i just thought we'd learn that
lesson around the jurassic world era
where he was also kind of announced like
in the same week as gonna be a young
indiana jones and it was like okay he
doesn't have to be everything you know
um that was my whole thing he's just
gonna be literally all over disneyland
by the time this is done like that dude
is literally on like well it just all
amusement parks he's gonna take down
knott's berry farm next with the snoopy
it's gonna happen
we're giving them too many ideas whitney
because he's already got universal he's
got disneyland he's got rides at both
knox berry firms next man we are now
willing this into existence
oh chris pratt i hope you don't play fat
albert that would be horrible hollywood
don't ever do that don't do it
ever do that like mike don't reprise
that
like mike
no dude honestly chris pratt would just
get cast as one of the golden retrievers
in air bud if anything
so that i'm okay with for whatever
reason i'm okay with that because i
don't already have an attachment of what
airbud sounds like so i don't you know i
don't really care if they make that dog
chris pratt looks like how a golden
retriever sounds yeah so you know like i
actually feel like that would i mean
andy dwyer was just a golden retriever
that a wizard transformed into a human
oh seriously like any and april
essentially a dog and a cat living
together oh yeah yes that's like a dog
in a cat forever whitney i've given you
the point for successfully scaring me
but mt i'm giving you another point for
saying that april and andy are a cat and
a dog
brilliant metaphor
either way mt ran away with this one
congratulations you are the winner of
this episode of roman reigns
you know what i'll share my victory we
all won i'm going to kill him
you are supposed to be the chosen one
jessica
well that is it for this episode of
rogue theory i want to thank all of our
guests whitney van laney they have
jessica clemens and mt you can support
our channel by checking out all of our
great merch options over at new
rockstarsmerch.com and including a new
eternals design that we have up there
you're gonna love it it's gonna go fast
though so jump on that follow me at
eavos follow the new rockstars on all
social platforms and be sure to
subscribe to our channel here on youtube
if you're not already and we'll see you
next time celestials
[Music]
you